-Last night was the Oscars
And I wanted to do
a whole piece about it,
but we ran out of time.
[ Gasp ]
-Well, how much time do we have?
-Oh! One minute.
-One minute is all I need.
-Both:
Start the clock!
-First of all,
everybody was beautiful.
I have kept a tab open
of Regina King's dress all. day!
And it has only gotten cuter
as time has passed!
Viola Davis looked outstanding
LaKeith Stanfield
was untouchable,
and Glenn Close
looked so perfect
and had on little black gloves
like she was about to commit
a dramatic murder.
And floppy bow ties are in
and you know what?
I do not care for that, at all
-35 seconds. You'd better ge
to who won what.
-Okay, I'm getting there.
Daniel Kaluuya made a speech
and then, they showed
his mom watching him
and she was like so proud.
And then, they cut back to him
and he was like,
"We're all going
to party tonight
because my mom and dad
had sex, so, hey!"
And then, they cut back to his
mom and she looked like this -
[ Laughs ] Then, the "Minari
grandma got up there
and did a [ Snapping fingers ]
tight five.
She was hilarious!
-Okay, but who won what?
-I'm getting to that!
And Renée cursed,
Glenn Close did Da Butt,
Francis McDormand
howled like a wolf,
and then, it ended all
of a sudden?
Just like "The Sopranos."
[ Buzzer ]
-Can you at least tell me
who was the big Oscar winner
from last night?
-That, I can do.
The big Oscar winner
from last night?
Well, ladies and gentlemen
that was none other
than fashion.
[ Romantic tune sweeps ]
-Oh, boy.
You said it was going
to be a minute
-Fashion was the winner.
-and I feel like you're really
[ Laughing ] overdoing it.
-Fashion!
-Amber Ruffin, everybody.
We will be right back
with "A Closer Look."
You're welcome to stay, Amber.
-I won't.
I have places to prance.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-♪♪ How do you ♪♪
-What is she doing?
Why can't we go to commercial?
-♪♪ Like the Oscars? ♪♪